WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW THIS PUBLIC PROCESS AN
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW I WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. I WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
ACCESS CODE SEVEN THREE SEVEN
ONE ONE FOUR. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS OLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT.
AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I ALSO MAINTAINED DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESS AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE MANNER AS
POSSIBLE- THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF.
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. NOW LET'S GET STARTED
WITH THE BUSINESS OF THE
COMMITTEE BY ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS CONSULTS
HERE DOES PRESENT BATES. HELLO
ARCHULETA ALL RIGHT MUCH LOVE
PRESENT DECKER THEIR PRESENT
QUOTATION. DOLLY THE- DOLLY
PRESENT DOT- DOT PRESENT BOOK
WHERE. MELINDA'S MEN. NEWMAN
NEWMAN PRESENT YEAH. SKYNYRD
NUMBER YEAH NUMBER PRESENT
HOUSEKEEPER MY PAST PRESENT
WELL. ONE SHORT OF A QUORUM
OKAY WE HAVE ONE SHORT OF A
QUORUM WILL BE WILL CONTINUE ON
AS A SUB COMMITTEE. THE MEMBERS
WE HAVE FOR SOME HOUSEKEEPING
FIRST SCR THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR ALLEN AN AB FIVE TWELVE
BY ASSEMBLYMAN. HOLDEN HAS BEEN
PUT OVER AT THIS TIME. WE ALSO
NINETEEN BILLS TWELVE OF WHICH
ARE CONSENTED TO IT MENTION
THAT ARE HELD OVER FIVE UP FOR
DISCUSSION TODAY. AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT CALENDAR THESE ARE THE
BILLS ON CONSENT. EIGHTY SEVEN
FORTY FOUR BY RODRIGUEZ EIGHTY
NINE NINETY TWO BUT COOLEY AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY LEE A.
B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
MULLEN. AT FOURTEEN NINETY NINE
DAILY AC R. THIRTY TWO MEGAN
DOLLY IS YOUR FORTY MATTIS AC
R. FORTY SEVEN STONE AGE HERE
FIFTY ONE GABRIEL EIGHTY OR
FIFTY TWO PATTERSON AC ARE
SIXTY FOUR LONG. AC ARE SIXTY
SEVEN QUICKSILVER. DOES ANYONE
HAVE ANY OBJECTION. TO BUILD ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SHE WAS.
OKAY SEE NONE- AND I BELIEVE WE
MAY HAVE ONE MEMBER THAT JUST
ARRIVED MR CONSULTANT CAN WE
ENSURE THAT. CALL THE S.
MEMBERS. LOCAL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MASTERIES SINNERS BATES.
ALAN CORTESE. WHERE WELL IN
THIS. MAN RUBIO. SKINNER. WELL
WE HAVE ONE SHOT OKAY WE'RE
STILL ON TRACK MY APOLOGIES I
THOUGHT I SAW ANOTHER MEMBER
COME IN. SO THE FIRST- WILL BE
BILLS PLUS A C. R. FIFTY ONE
THE SECOND WILL BE THE
REMAINING NAMING SOLUTIONS-
NAMING RESOLUTIONS CONSULTANT
CAN WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WITH THE R. WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT. APOLOGIES WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON. AS WE STILL HAVE NOT
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. OKAY SO
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER TASHA
BOERNER HORVATH. I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE YOU
ARE GOING TO PRESENT ON. AB ONE
ONE SEVEN GO RIGHT AHEAD THANK
YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE
AND SENATORS TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
PRESENT A B. ONE ONE SEVEN A
BILL TO ALLOW E. BIKE
INCENTIVES TO BE ONE OF THE
PRIORITIES ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING
UNDER THE AIR QUALITYIMPROVEMENT PROGRAM. BY
INCREASING EBRIGHT ADOPTION WE
ARE ABLE TO REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED A RECENT STUDY
IN THE NORTH AMERICAN E. BIKE
OWNER SHOW THAT NEARLY HALF OR
FORTY SIX PERCENT. E. BIKE
COMMUTE TRIPS REPLACED
AUTOMOBILE COMMUTE TRIPS TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
GOALS WE MUST WORK TO REDUCE
THE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
REPLACE THEM WITH CLEANER
ALTERNATIVES. EVEN I GET OPTION
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER THE PAST YEAR BUT COSTS
REMAIN A FACTOR AND FOR
AVAILABILITY FOR SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS I'M WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL ENSURE THE
PROGRAM PRIORITIZES LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. INCLUDING THE USE
OF SALARY CAP FOR THESE
INCENTIVES GO TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY NEED THEM. WE'RE ALSO
WORKING ON A MOMENT BASED ON
COMMITTEE SUGGESTIONS THAT
WOULD STRUCTURE THIS AS A
VOUCHER PROGRAM SO- DOUBLE
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE PRE APPROVED
FOR INCENTIVES AND WALK INTO A
PARTICIPATING RETAILER TO
PURCHASE AN E. BIKE USING THE
VOUCHER. FINALLY WE HAVE TAKEN
A MOMENT THAT WILL HELP ENSURE
INCENTIVES CAN BE USED FOR A
VARIETY OF BIKES FOR DIFFERENT
ABILITIES WHAT- THAT A SMALL
PORTION OF ANY FUNDING
ALLOCATED TO THIS PROGRAM
COURTSHIP OF TOWARDS. THE BACK
EDUCATION AND SAFETY. PROGRAM
AND THAT WE ENSURE APPROPRIATE.
TO PREVENT FRAUD AND ABUSE OF
THE PROGRAM. SENATORS EIGHTY
ONE SEVENTEEN WE'LL WAIT HE
BIKES MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
CALIFORNIANS ALLOWING MORE
PEOPLE ADOPT THIS CLEANER
HEALTHIER FORM OF
TRANSPORTATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I WROTE IT WITH ME ON
THE LINE I BELIEVE I HAVE MY
WITNESS STEVE SCHNEIDER. THE
CALIFORNIA BY COALITION. OKAY
THANK YOU- ASSEMBLYWOMAN AND
WE'LL GO AHEAD WITH YOUR SEARCH
YOUR- PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT DAVE SNYDER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION-
MISTER MODERATOR MS MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE BRING HIM ON THE
LINE. I DO NOT DIAL THEM AT
THIS TIME. OKAY HE'S NOT ON THE
LINE AT THIS TIME OKAY THEN
WE'LL GO AHEAD- AS WE'RE
WAITING FOR HIM WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND CONTINUE ON WITH WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE LINE. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE ONE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
FOUR LINES IN Q. OR MOTOR LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
NOT YOUR MOM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU I AM TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KERR COLLECTING ON THE
UP THE SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS SANDAG AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. IF YOU DON'T IF
YOU WANT A MOMENT TO THE NEXT
COMMENTS. NINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NOT INSURED MEMBER SO
THEY HAD TO LEAVE SHANTI
HAPPENS AT CITY OF LOS ANGELES
IS THE PART THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT COMMENT FOR MY
TWENTY FOURTH BEFORE I HAD.
ENGINEERING THE POLISH FOR
CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR AND WE
LIKE TO ASK YOU AND IF YOU CAN
CHECK AGAIN IF THE PRIMARY
WITNESS STEVE SNYDER IS ON THE
LINE. I DO NOT. FIND OUT YET.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THEN WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK TO THE GALLERY IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE ONE SEVEN. THREE NINE- WE
HAVE ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY THERE THE
MAN. OKAY AND SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE THEM ON THE LINE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION EITHER- AS MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANBODY ON THE LINE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. ONE ONE
SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
ONE ONE SEVEN THREE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE A LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ENGAGED WRITER HAS
JOINED US OKAY THEN LET'S GO
BACK TO MISTER SNYDER IN
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY ONE ONE
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I'M
SORRY THAT I MISSED THE D.
PRESENTATION EARLIER. IT SAID
TWO MINUTES TO. TALK TO YOU
ABOUT IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL
BE OUR GUEST PLEASE MR SNYDER
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY AND
WE'RE TAKING A FEW MINUTES
THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU. HI
I'M AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION. OUR MISSION IS TO
HELP COMMUNITY BE BETTER.
OFFERS MORE EQUITABLE HEALTHIER
SAFER MORE INCLUSIVE AND MORE
JOYFUL. BECAUSE LIKE YOU'RE
GOING TO DO ALL OF THAT WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED SAFER STREETS
WE'RE GETTING A LOT MORE MONEY
IN SAFER STREETS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION BOXES BEING ADDED TO
THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM- BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
HELPING PEOPLE GET E. BIKES
WILL HELP US MAKE A LOT MORE
PROGRESS. GET MORE OUT OF. IT'S
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
HOW MUCH FURTHER YOU CAN GO
WITH E. BIKES TO REALIZE HOW
MUCH FUN IT IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WILL RIDE THE BIKE TO CURRENTLY
LONG RIDE. ALSO THAT YOU'D LIKE
TO MAKE PEOPLE FEEL SAFER
THAT'S- THE RESULTS FROM OUR
SURVEY ON. ABOUT EIGHTEEN
pUSERS THAT I WILL. REFER TO
LATER. THIS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
WITH S. E. BIKES WILL INCREASE
THE DEMAND FOR ALL KINDS. AND
HELP US MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
SAFER PROCESS SYSTEMIC.
INFLUENCE THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE THAT WE CAN'T
OVERLOOK AND WE HAVE TO SUPPORT.
ALSO HELP IN A VERY DIRECT WAY
AS WELL WE KNOW FROM THAT
SURVEY THAT ABOUT HALF THE
PEOPLE TAKE ON ME BY- MOORE HAD
BEEN CARTRIDGE AND A CARTRIDGE
WOULD HAVE AVERAGED ABOUT NINE
POINT THREE MILES SO THE-
NUMBER OF THIS CAR TRIPS THEY
REDUCED BY ME BY. GARY
SUBSTANTIAL AND GETTING WORTH.
THE INVESTMENT IT'S ON- AND
COST EFFECTIVENESS ACCORDING TO
ONE STUDY EVEN BETTER THAN THAT
THE SUPPORT WE GET FOR ELECTRIC
CAR CONTRIBUTES TO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS- STUDY- LIKE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AROUND. HI
TREE THAT LOOKED AT FOUR IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN ARE EITHER
ONGOING OR HAD EXPIRED BECAUSE
THEIR DEMAND OUTSTRIPS SUPPLY
THAT WOULD BE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY SAN DIEGO COUNTRY
CONFIDENTIAL WALMART ALL THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE OVER SUBSCRIBED
AND WOULD BE WOULD BENEFIT FROM
A BILL THAT WOULD SUPPORT.
SUBSIDIES OKAY ABOUT SHOES TO
HELP PEOPLE GET INTO THE REALLY
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY AND I
HOPE YOU CHECK IN AND I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE US AND THE
NUMBER OF US FOUR HUNDRED
SHEETS FOR ENCOURAGE. YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU MR. QUESTION YOU
MIGHT ASK THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US SO
THAT HAS CONCLUDED OUR SUPPORT
ONCE AGAIN- AGAIN MODERATOR WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION NOW WILL TURN TO
THAT FOR. AB ONE ONE SEVEN.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMON THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
GALLERY ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ONE ONE SEVEN C. NINE. ROOM
ONE TWELVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
THERE SEE NONE. SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. AND BEFORE WE- GO
BACK TO MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
INSURE THAT WE ESTABLISHED ONCE
AGAIN A QUORUM MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU. CALL THE
MEMBERS SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BEFORE I PROCEED. THE
SENATE DEBATES. HELLO CORTESE
CORTESE PRESENT WHERE BELINDA'S
IN RUBIO SKINNER WILL PRESIDENT
WILL PRESENT YOU HAVE A POINT
GREAT FANTASTIC WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER FOR YOUR PATIENCE
SO IT'S IMPORTANT OPPOSITION
WERE GONNA TAKE IT BACK TO
MEMBER SENATOR ARCHULETA. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND TO
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND I
SEE IT IS OF A WAY OF LEVELING
THE PLAYING FIELD BECAUSE IT
DOES BRING THE LOWER INCOME
MODERATE INCOME. PEOPLE INTO
PLAY AND THE IN THE EQUALITY
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT OF COURSE THE
ENVIRONMENT. IS ALWAYS AN
ISSUE- AND WITH THE FACT THAT-
YOU'VE DONE YOUR RESEARCH AND
IT SHOWS THAT THE E. BIKES ARE
NEW FORMS. OF TRANSPORTATION
FOR THOSE WHO- OR GOING TO
SCHOOL OR WORK IN THE ECONOMY
COMING BACK HOPEFULLY. THEY
CAN- PURCHASED ONE OF THESE BUT
IN SOME OF THE PRICES. ARE A
LITTLE EXCESSIVE AND WITH THE
AID OF THE STATE I THINK WE'LL
OPEN UP A NEW DOOR. SO I WOULD-
BE HONORED TO BE A CO AUTHOR
AND I WOULD MOVE THE BILL WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE. UNDER FULL
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA
HE'S MOVED THE BILL ON AB ONE
ONE SEVEN I SEE NO OTHER MIKES
UP SO SIMPLY WOMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. HAVE A- GREAT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN WE- CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HI IN DALLAS HI BATES.
ELLEN MARCH ELEVENTH I WATCH A
LITTLE I. BECKER BECKER HI
CORTESE ALL RIGHT WHAT IS IT HI
DOLLY. DOT I DON HI WHERE.
BLENDERS MAN. NEWMAN NEWMAN I
REVEAL. SKINNER NUMBER THE
QUAKE OWSKI HI KELSEY I WILL HI
WELL I. APRIL IT'S WONDERFUL
ABLE TO LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN AND
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIR
WE'RE GOING ON TO OUR SECOND
BILL AND FILE ORDER WHICH IS AB
NINE FIVE FIVE WELCOME MR CORK.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
BUT DUE TO CONFUSION ABOUT
APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
PROJECT PERMITS SOME BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS HAVE
BEEN DELAYED BY OVER A YEAR. KV
NINE FIFTY FIVE REQUIRES
CALTRANS TO NOTIFY ENCROACHMENT
PERMIT APPLICANTS OF ALL
APPLICABLE REQUIREMENTS UP
FRONT. IT'S A IT'S A THIRTY DAY
MILESTONE FOR PATRONS TO VERIFY
WHETHER THAT APPLICATION IS
COMPLETE. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS BERNIE MARASCO FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. WONDERFUL THANK YOU
MR CLARK AND WE'LL GO ON TO MR
ROSCOE WHO IS HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WITH US GO RIGHT AHEAD
MR RUSKO. CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A.
B. NINE FIVE FIVE. THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT WILL PROVIDE SOME
CERTAINTY IN THE PERMITTING
PROCESS. DOES NOT CHANGE THE
CURRENT LAW AND WE WILL SEE THE
CALTRANS WILL STILL HAVE SIXTY
DAYS TO RESPOND. BUT THIS SET
SOME MILESTONES WITHIN THAT
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE IT IS
CLEAR. THAT WE HAVE YOU
COMPLETED A PROJECT
ENCROACHMENT PERMIT. REQUESTED
SO THAT WE CAN QUICKLY DEPLOY
BROADBAND AS YOU KNOW BROADBAND
IS ONE OF THE HOTTEST ISSUES
THIS YEAR. THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT DEPLOYMENT OF
NEW FACILITIES MADAM CHAIR YOU
HAVE YOUR OWN AS BEFORE THIS
WOULD COMPLEMENT THAT MEASURE
VERY NICELY- WE HOPE TO HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR ROSCOE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SO WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF AB. NINE FIVE FIVE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT S. EIGHTY EIGHT NINE
FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
WILL TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF A. B. NINE
FIVE FIVE IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NONE. ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
IN SUPPORT THE MAN. THAT
CONCLUDES SUPPORT THERE'S NO-
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME BUT WE'LL TAKE IT
TO THE LINES IF THERE'S ANYONE-
MODERATOR IN OPPOSITION OF AB
NINE FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- EIGHTY NINE FIVE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME GREAT THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY C. NINE. ROOM ONE
TWELVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB NINE FIVE FIVE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE C. NONE- AND SO NOW WE
WILL TAKE IT TO MEMBERS ANY.
YES SENATOR AKOWSKI SEE WHEN MY
MANAGER THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE I MOVE IT. WONDERFUL
THANK YOU SENATOR MCCASKEY I
SEE NO OTHER MAKES UP I WOULD
ALSO SAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. AS MR ROSCOE
MENTIONEDMANY OF US ARE
CARRYING BROADBAND BILLS WE
WANT FASTER DEPLOYMENT THIS
SEEMS VERY COMMON SENSE AND
STREAMLINED AND WITH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. MY EYES FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR CLARK
SO WITH THAT TO BE A MOTION
THAT WE DID WITH SENATOR
AKOWSKI SEMESTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HI IN DOLLARS HI BATES.
ALAN ARCHULETA HI BARCELONA HI
BECKER AT BECKER HIGH CORTESE I
PUT EASY HI DOLLY PARTON DOLLY
HI DOT. HI DON HI GLAD.
MELINDA'S MEN. NEWMAN HI NEWMAN
HI RUBIO. SKINNER HUMBERT BY
KELSEY HI BY KELSEY HI WILL HI
WELL ON. NINE VOTES HAS ENOUGH
TO GET OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE THE
BILL ON THE CALL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. WONDERFUL SO
NEXT WE'LL GO A LITTLE BIT OUT
OF ORDER BECAUSE I DO SEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS HERE SO WE
WILL GO WITH HIM NEXT TO
PRESENT AP AT TEN THIRTY FIVE
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS-
FIRSTLY LIKE START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
THIRTY FIVE WILL HELP THE STATE
MEDIA MEET ITS ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS BY REQUIRING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ADOPT THE SAME
RECYCLED MATERIAL STANDARDS AS
CALTRANS BY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. TO THE EXTENT FEASIBLE
AND COST EFFECTIVE. AND
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX
REQUIRING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
EVALUATE ADOPTING THE STANDARDS
EVERY THREE YEARS THE USE OF
RECYCLED CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS
HELP CONSERVE NATURAL. SOURCES
OF AGGREGATES PRESERVING BODY
TO ENERGY OF MANUFACTURED
CONCRETE AND ASPHALT CONCERT
WILL. RESOURCES AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES FROM LESS
TRANSPORTED PRODUCTION OF NEW
MATERIALS- WITH THAT BUT I'M
SURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
PHONE THANK YOU SEMI MEMBER AND
YOU DO HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT CHARLIE REY
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION AND
INDUSTRIAL MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION. ON THE LINE-
MODERATOR CAN YOU ENSURE THAT
MR. R. OR MISERY IS ON THE LINE
PLEASE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
THANK YOU THIS IS CHARLIE RAG.
YOU CAN HEAR ME YES WE CAN'T.
HI MY NAME IS CHARLIE RED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION AND
INDUSTRIAL MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION. CALCIUM IS MADE UP
PRODUCE ROCK SAND GRAVEL AND
OTHER MATERIALS THAT HELP BUILD
OUR ROADS BRIDGES RAIL TRANSIT
AND OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE. WE'VE
BEEN INCORPORATING RECYCLED
MATERIALS CONSTRUCTION
MATERIALS AND OUR PRODUCT OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES. YEAH
HELP KEEP HEAVY AND BULKY
MATERIALS OUT OF OUR LANDFILLS
AND REDUCES GREENHOUSE GASES.
PORTLY CALTRANS TO DEVELOP
SPECIFICATIONS THAT ALLOW THE
USE OF RECYCLED MATERIALS AND
PAYMENTS AND MANY CITIES DO
THIS AS WELL. UNFORTUNATELY
THOUGH THERE ARE SOME CITIES
AND COUNTIES THAT EITHER
PROHIBIT OR LIMIT THE USE OF
RECYCLED CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS.
THIS BILL THEN THAT WANTED TO
BE THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
CITIES AND COUNTIES SHOULD HAVE
SPECIFICATIONS EQUIVALENT TO
CAL TRANS STANDARD
SPECIFICATIONS FOR THE USE OF
RECYCLED MATERIALS IN ROAD BASE
ASPHALT AND CONCRETE. THANK YOU
JUST A COUPLE OF IMPORTANT
THINGS TO NOTE ABOUT THE BILL
WANTED ONLY USES CALTRANS
CURRENT STANDARDS
SPECIFICATIONS IT'S NOT ABOUT
THE SPECIFICATIONS THAT ARE IN
A TRIAL OR DEVELOPMENT MENTAL
STAGE. ALSO IT ALLOWS FOR
FUTURE CALTRANS STANDARD
SPECIFICATIONS ON RECYCLED
MATERIALS TO BE INCORPORATED.
AND REALLY ALL TOGETHER WE FEEL
LIKE THIS BILL RESPECTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT INCREASES RECYCLING
A PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS AND
ASSIST WITH THE STATE REACHING
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
IMPLEMENTATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU MYSTERY SO WE'VE CONFIRMED
CONCLUDED OUR PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT A MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AT TEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL TAKE IT TO THE GALLERY
ANYONE IN SUPPORT TO TEN THIRTY
FIVE C. NINE. ROOM ONE TWELVE
WE SEE NO- WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT THEIR- WE'LL TAKE IT TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY.
A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION- BUT
MODERATE OR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION ON THE LINE
PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AT
TEN THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO COMMENTS
THANK YOU IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST COMMENT
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
KAREN NUMBERS THIS IS
CRITICALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE HAD AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL AT THE END PRINT I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK TO
CLARIFY ANY COST EFFECTIVE IN
FEASIBILITY AND CONSTRAINT TAT
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE ALLOWED TO
LOOK AT AND ALSO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE CONSULTED. AS
THESE STANDARDS ARE UPDATED IN
THE FUTURE I WOULD THINK THAT'S
A GOOD COMPROMISE THAT GOES A
LONG WAY TOWARDS ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS WE HAVE WITH THE BILL
AND APPRECIATE THE WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR TO
RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT TO THE NEXT COMMENT.
LINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- DAMON
CONKLIN WITH LEGAL CALIFORNIA
CITIES JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
OVER AT THE- COUNTIES- WE TOO
ARE APPRECIATED THE WILLINGNESS
OF THE AUTHOR TO- WORK WITH US
AND KEEP THE CONVERSATION GOING
THE AMENDMENTS HOUSE- DRIVES
MUCH OF OUR CONCERNS. REGARDING
FEASIBILITY AND- THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS AND- LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
THE BUILDING AT THE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MODERATOR SO WE OF
CONCLUDED THE OPPOSITION
ACTUALLY LET ME GO TO THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION OF TEN
THIRTY FIVE C. NINE. ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE SEE NO OPPOSITION
THERE AS WELL- SO WE'LL TAKE IT
BACK TO MEMBERS FOR DISCUSSION
ON A. B. TEN THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE. SENATOR ARCHULETA HE
MOVES THE BILL WONDERFUL WE
HAVE A MOTION THERE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WONDERFUL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS- THEY DO GO A LONG
WAY FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE
APPRECIATE THAT. MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS CONSULTS HI CONSULTA
BATES. ALAN ARCHULETA HI MUCH
LATER HI- HI BECKER I PUT DAISY
HI PORTES ET HI DALI. DALI HI
DOT I DO NOT HI. MELINDA'S MEN.
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN HI BILL.
SKINNER NUMBER HI HI BY KELSEY
HI THE COUNTY HIGH WILL ALL
RIGHT WILL I. TENANTS THANK YOU
LOOKS LIKE IT HAS ENOUGH TO GET
UP AND LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER AND
WELCOME ASSEMBLYWOMAN THREE OF
US- TO PRESENT ON HER BILL
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR THANK
YOU WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS I WANT TO BEGIN MY
STATEMENT TODAY ADDRESSING
RUMORS THAT C. H. P. IS IN
OPPOSITION TO MY BILL I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT C. H. P. THE DOES
NOT AND HAS NOT TAKEN A
POSITION ON MY BILL. MY TEAM
AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THEM AND THE COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS- CHP'S CONCERNS- I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR THOROUGH EVALUATION
OF THE SPELL AND FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN S. B. EIGHT
ZERO SIX AUTHORIZE THE DMB TO
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
VEHICLE REGISTRATION
ALTERNATIVES. AND REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE RESULT
RESULTS OF THE PILOT PROGRAM.
THE PILOT PROGRAM ALLOWED
SPECIALTY PLATE OWNERS TO RENEW
THE REGISTRATION ELECTRONICALLY
THROUGH DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE
PROVIDERS AND ALLOW.
INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS THE
REGISTRATION INFORMATION FROM
THE LICENSE PLATES OUT
ESTABLISHED BY THE LICENSE
PLATES PROVIDER. THIS PILOT
PROGRAM FOUND THAT THESE
ALTERNATIVE REGISTRATION
IMPROVED EFFICIENCY AT THE DMV
BY ALLOWING SPECIALTY PLATE
OWNERS TO RENEW THE
REGISTRATION VIA A MOBILE APP
RATHER THAN HAVING TO GO INTO
THE DMV. A. B. NINE EIGHTY FOUR
WILL IMPLEMENT THE FINDINGS FOR
THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION
ALTERNATIVE PILOT PROGRAM BY
AUTHORIZING THE DMV IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CHP TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION CARDS.
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES AND
LICENSE PLATE WRAPS TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I HAVE GYM LIGHTS REPRESENTING
REVIVER. THANK YOU AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I JUST WANT TO INSURE
THAT YOU'VE ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WONDERFUL
SO WE'LL MOVE TO YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS AND SUPPORT MISTER JIM
LITES WITH REVIVER MODERATOR DO
YOU HAVE HIM ON THE COASTLINE.
YES SO I DON'T KNOW MAN THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JIM LIVES ON BEHALF
OF REVIVER AGAIN- AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RELIVES INDICATED WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
ALONG WITH THE DMV LCD SCREEN
AND THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FOR
COLLABORATING ON THE BODY OF
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING
ADOPTED TODAY. WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THERE MAY BE FURTHER
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS COMING
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY-
SHOULD THAT OCCUR WE WILL
CERTAINLY CIRCLE BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE TO- TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THOSE AMENDMENTS I'D ALSO LIKE
TO NOTE THAT WE CAN USE
SAMPLING. WE TOOK- A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION AND THROUGH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE WE REMAIN IN ACTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ACLU AND
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU MR LIGHTS SO
MODERATOR WE JUST WANT TO
INSURE THAT THERE ISN'T ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR. IF YOU
WISH IF IN. OF EIGHT NINETY
FOUR PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE TWO
LINES IN HUMOR WRITING TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHRIS
ROSA ON BEHALF OF THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. FIND
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEDICARE MEMBERS OF MY
COMMUNITY HELP OF LIFE WHICH IS
A SMALL FAMILY OWNED. BUSINESS
IN ORANGE COUNTY THAT PROVIDE
BY COMPLETE ALTERNATIVE WE
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR
IT IS GOOD INNOVATION IS THE
POLICY WE'VE HAD- SOME
EXCHANGES WITH INTERESTED
PARTIES ON A COUPLE OF
OPERATIONAL ISSUES AND WORK
COMP AND THOSE WILL RESULT-
VERY QUICKLY. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR- SO WE'LL GO TO THE
GALLERY FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
FOUR C. NINE WE'LL GO TO RED
ROOM ONE TWELVE. C. NINE. SO
NOW WILL FLIP OVER TO
OPPOSITION MODERATOR WE DO HAVE
I BELIEVE A PRIMARY WITNESS AN
OPPOSITION BACKER CREAMER
MOTOR. FROM THE ACLU ON THE
LINE PLEASE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO I'M BACK AT KRAMER MATTER
ON BEHALF AND IF YOU FEEL YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN OPPOSITION
HE BEAT NINETY FOUR A MONTH BUT
AT THE MOMENT. HELLO LIKE
WEIGHT AND THEN IT'LL BE IT
ALREADY CARD RIGHT HI IS THE
ONLY THING AND ACCORDING. THAT
MUST BE ADDRESSED PRIOR TO
MAKING THESE PROGRAMS. WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR IN FRONT
IN TO SOME OF OUR CONDUCT AND
THEN. THE AMENDMENT TAKEN FAR
DO NOT ADDRESS OUR MAIN CONCERN
WITH THESE PROGRAMS. FOR THE
NOT REJECTED INCOME AS WOULD
ALLOWED TO GATHER FROM USERS OR
OTHER DEVICES. ELECTRONIC
DEVICES CAN GATHER SENSITIVE
INFORMATION SUCH AS LOCATION
GOT IT MAKING IT VITAL THAT BB
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR CLEAR
CLEAR LIMITATIONS ON WHAT
INFORMATION THE VENDOR MAY
COLLECT. WELL THE USER A GOOD
LITTLE PLAY OR RIGHT. DEVICE
COPS FOR THE VEHICLE OWNER THAT
DOES NOT MEAN THAT ALL USERS OF
THE VEHICLE AND CONSENTED TO
GPS TRACKING. BUT IN FACT NOT
ONLY EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SUCH AS
PEOPLE ESCAPING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. COULD BE TRACKED BY
OTHER USERS BECAUSE I THINK. WE
CAN AMENDMENT DID NOT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS. ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
FAILING ON WHAT FORM DIGITAL
VEHICLE. REGISTRATION CARD.
NEITHER OF THEM THE DOOR FOR
ACCESS OF PERSONAL LOCATION AT
ALL TIMES. AS WELL AS TRACKING
WEBSITE THE PRINCE THERE THAT
ARE CALM AND MORE. SECOND THE
BILL ARE AN INCREASE ABOUT ONE
OF DR FIBER. THAT ALL TIME LIFE
PLATE FEE READABLE BY AUTOMATED
LICENSE PLATE READER OFTEN
KNOWN AS ALE PR. YEAH CAN AND
ALLOW THINGS LOOK BLEAK CARDS
RECORD MORE THAN FOURTEEN
THOUSAND PLATE OR A SINGLE
SHOT. THEY CAN BE USED TO
REVEAL NOT ONLY WHERE A PERSON
LIVES AND WORK. WITH THEIR
POLITICAL AND RELIGIOUS BELIEFS
SOCIAL AND SEXUAL HABITS. HELLO
DOCTOR HE ENTERED MY PLATES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO BE READ BY THE
THIRD ROUND TECHNOLOGY AND
NEITHER SHOULD. ULTIMATELY PLAY.
DO YOU REMEMBER NOW DAY FAX IT
HAS A NINE EIGHTY FOUR A MONTH
AND THEN AT THE YEAH. THANK YOU.
SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AS
PRIMARY WITNESSES SO MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB NINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I DO HAVE ONE COMMON VIEW
LINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER PADDLING AT THE ENTER
THE CORPORATE ANTI THERE ON
BEHALF OF THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE AND ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN
OPPOSITION I MEAN LIKE THE
LETTER COMMENT BUT AT LEAST THE
ACTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYMORE COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
MODERATOR. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WILL TAKE
IT TO THE GALLERY ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION THERE C. NINE ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN OPPOSITION SEE
NONE. WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS SENATOR MCCASKEY. YEAH
MAN- SHARE I THINK TO THERE ARE
SOME LEGITIMATE PRIVACY.
MATTERS ON THIS BILL THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED. BUT I WHILE I SIT
ON THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I'M
SITTING AS A MEMBER OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. S. N.
FROM UP TRANSPORTATION
PERSPECTIVE IN A TECHNOLOGY
PERSPECTIVE I THINK THIS
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY THAT'S
OFFERED BY THIS SO WELL I
RESERVE MY RIGHT TO. LOOK AT
THE RESTRICTION OFFENDERS WHICH
I BELIEVE IS A JUDICIARY
QUESTIONED ON THE PRIVACY. I AM
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE- TODAY WITH A
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU SENATOR
AKOWSKI AND I SEE NO OTHER
MIKES UP YOU TOOK THE WORDS
RIGHT OUT OF MY MOUTH ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BUT AS CHURCH
TRANSPORTATION THIS IS- THIS IS
BEEN ESTABLISHED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THERE WAS A PRO
PILOT PROGRAM TO EVALUATE THE
DMV AND THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES-
INSURING THAT RENEWALS ARE.
EASIER AND FASTER AND THERE'S
ALSO SECURITY MEASURES WITH
ENCRYPTION AND PASSWORD
pTHE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION AS WELL TO
CLARIFY- SOME ADDITIONAL-
AMENDMENTS. OUT WITH NO OTHER
MAKES UP WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE. OKAY
SENATOR BOOKER THANK YOU MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATORS CONSULTS FIVE DOLLARS
HI IT'S- ALAN. SUCH A LETTER I
HEARD LITTLE HI BECKER HI
BECKER I PUT EIGHT BY CORTESE
HI. DOLLY. DOT HI DONNA HI
WHERE. MELINDA'S MAN. NEWMAN
RUBIO FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER.
AMBER HI AMBER I LIKE ASKING HI
WHAT ELSE DO I WILL HI WILL HI.
NINE VOTES THANK YOU IT LOOKS
LIKE THAT HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT
BUT WE WILL PUT THE PUT THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU SOME
REMEMBER THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
AND LAST BILL UP FOR DISCUSSION
TODAY AND THEN WE'LL HAVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IMMEDIATELY
AFTERWARDS IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLLY WELCOME HE'LL BE
PRESENTING ON AB. ELEVEN NINETY
SIX. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRMAN SENATORS. I'M PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT A DIFFERENT
BILL AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX THIS
WILL REVISE THE STATUTE
GOVERNING THE SECTOR REGIONAL
TRANSIT BOARD TO PERMIT IS
BOARD VOTING STRUCTURE. TO
RETURN EXCLUSIVELY TOLD ONE
PERSON ONE VOTE METHODOLOGY
WHICH IS TYPICAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES STATEWIDE- BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX IT ALTERED AS
VOTING OF METHODOLOGY BECAUSE
ONE JURISDICTION THE CITY
VELCRO DID NOT PARTICIPATE AS A
FULL ON AGENCY SO IT WAS ONE
PERSON ONE VOTE AS EVERYONE
ELSE AND FINANCIALLY WEIGHTED
SYSTEM FOR ELK GROVE'S
INCLUSION AND PARTICIPATION.
THEY ARE NOW A PART OF THE
AGENCY GET A TRANSIT SERVICES
TO SACK PARTY THE WEIGHTED
VOTING SYSTEM THEREFORE IS AN
ANACHRONISM THIS BILL JUST
MAKES YOU UNIFORM ACROSS THEIR
ADMINISTRATION A REQUEST. AND I
WILL NO OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
SOMEONE. AND YOU DO HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT THAT
IS JOE FEEL BORED HAHA I
BELIEVE FROM SOCCER T. THIS
CORRECT OKAY WONDERFUL
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE A- TO FEEL
MORE HOT ON THE LINE PLEASE.
CAROLINA'S OFFENSE. GOOD
MORNING THERE ARE NUMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FINANCIAL AND ON
BEHALF OF THE DOCUMENTARY
REGIONAL DISTRICT AND PRETEXT
BUT THE PORT ON A. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SIX WE THINK THAT WOMEN
TRULY IT'S BATH AND TENNIS
TRANSPORTATION BACK AND WORKING
WITH THE FUND ITSELF. MENTIONED
BILL WITH SIMPLIFIED TRACKER
KEEP VOTING SYSTEM FROM AN
INTRICATE WEIGHTED STRUCTURE
COMPATIBLE ONE PERSON ONE VOTE
METHODOLOGY IN LINE WITH MOST
PUBLIC AGENCIES BIG Y.
PRESIDENT FOURTEEN ADAMANTLY BY
OUR REPORT AND ALL THE CITIES
IN OUR DISTRICT AND EXCHANGE
EMPOWERS THE BOARD TO ENSURE
EQUITY AND ACCESS ENCOURAGING
COMMUNITY DIALOGUE WITH LUCK
COMPLEXITY. ON HOW TO ADVOCATE
FOR BUT- NEARLY SIXTEEN YEARS A
PACKER TEACHING PRODUCE TO THAT
OF A WAY VOTING. AND THE WITH
FIVE HAVE NOT BEEN AND ACTING
TOWARDS. IN THAT CHOKE
CONTRIBUTE A PORTION OF THEIR
TRANSIT FUNDING TO SUPPORT
TRYING TO TERMINATE WITHIN. ANY
CHANGE IN EXCHANGE FOR KEEPING
OUR COURT. LAST FOUR YEARS. HE
HAD A COUPLE IN INVITING ARE
PARTICIPATING AND THE FEEDBACK
ADEQUATE TOWARD DISTRICT WE
EXPANDED OUR SERVICES INCLUDE
COMMUNICATIVE ANYBODY WOULD LET
TRANSFERS AN INSURED REGIONAL
INVESTMENTS REGARDLESS OF CITY
BOUNDARY. WITH ALACRITY ABOUT
GROWTH AND THAT EACH ENTRY. ON
THE BOARD WILL NOT BE A MEMBER
AGENCIES. MAKING THAT STRUCTURE
SO WE- WOULD PUT OUR COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS- AND WE CONTINUE TO
HELP THE REGION REBOUND BACK
EVEN STRONGER. ECONOMY REAL
QUICK. THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING
THE SOCCER TEAM AND ALL OF OUR
TRACK EIGHTEEN PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA WITH FAMILY EVERY
STATE EXCEPT FOR ONE THING WHAT
TRANSPORTATION FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST HERE I GO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER GORE HA. THE MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX PLEASE. THANK OU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
EIGHT ZERO ELEVEN NINETY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR
SO WE'LL GO TO THE GALLERY
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF A B.
ELEVEN NINETY SIXTY NINE. ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
SUPPORT TEAM THEN. THEY WILL
TAKE IT OVER TO OPPOSITION YOU
HAVE NO PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION THANKFULLY- ANYONE
ON THE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND WE'LL TAKE IT TO
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION TO
ELEVEN NINETY SIX C. NINE ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN OPPOSITION C.
NINE. MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO YOU- FOR
QUESTIONS ON A. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SIX FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLLY. C. NINE DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. WITH THAT SENATOR WILL
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I REQUEST
ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WILL
GO TO OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR
THE ROLL CALL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS IN REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS CONSULTS HIINTEL IS I
BET IT'S- ALAN. MARCH ELEVENTH
HI ARCHULETA HI BECKER BECKER
HI CORTESE RIGHT FOUR DAYS AGO
HI DOLLY HI DOLLY I THOUGHT I'D
DONE HI WHERE. BELINDA'S MIN.
NEWMAN IT WILL BE UP BY RUBIO
HI SKINNER. NUMBER FIVE NUMBER
HI LIKE HEALTHY HI WHAT KASKY
HIGH WILL I WILL HI. CONDUCTS
OKAY TEN VOTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOOKS LIKE THAT HAS ENOUGH TO
GET UP AND LEAVE THIS ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WONDERFUL
MEMBERS YOU'VE GOTTEN THROUGH
FIVE BILLS CONGRADULATIONS
RUSHING TO GO BACK TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- ONCE AGAIN S.
C. R. THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
ALLEN IN EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN HAS BEEN
PUT. OVER AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR THE
BILLS AGAIN ON CONSENT EIGHTY
SEVEN FORTY FOUR RODRIGUEZ NINE
NINETY TWO COOLEY THIRTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN LEAD THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR MULLEN FOURTEEN
NINETY NINE DAILY ACR THIRTY
TWO MEGAN DOLLY ACR FORTY
MATHIS AC ARE- FORTY SEVEN
STONE ACR FIFTY ONE GABRIEL IS
YOUR FIFTY TWO PATTERSON EASIER
FOR SIXTY FOUR PHONE EIGHT ZERO
SIXTY SEVEN COURT SILVA- DO YOU
HAVE ANY OBJECTION TO ANY BILL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SEE
NONE. CAN WE GET A MOTION FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE
SENATOR VALLEY WONDERFUL. AND
WILL HAVE TO CALL IT WE HAVE TO
CONCERN THAT WE WILL HAVE TWO
CONSECUTIVE THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER- SO FOR ON THE FIRST
ONE CAN WE GET A MOTION WE HAVE
ONE BY SENATOR DOLLY MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT. SO ON THE
FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF ABF. SEVENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE NINE TWO A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AP
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR A. B.
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE AND CASEY
ARE FIFTY ONE. THIRTEEN DOLLARS
HI HI. IT'S HELEN HI HELEN HI
BUT YOU LET IT HI MUCH LATER HI
RECORDS. DESPITE RECORD HIGH
CORTESE I GO TO THE HIGH VOLUME
HI JULIE HI DOT. I DON HI WHERE.
MELINDA'S MEN. NEWMAN HIGH
REVIEW. RUBIO HI SKINNER
SKINNER HI NUMBER HI NUMBER I
LIKE HEALTHY HI KELSEY HI PHIL.
THIRTEEN BOATS OKAY AND I THINK
I MAY HAVE SAID THINGS- AND
THAT ONE WAS PLUS ACR FIFTY ONE
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER ON THE
SECOND CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE
ALL RIGHT AHEAD. WHICH CONSISTS
OF. ACR THIRTY TWO PC ARE FORTY
FIFTY OR FORTY SEVEN. ACR FIFTY
TWO. AC ARE SIXTY FOUR AND AC
ARE SIXTY SEVEN. THIRD CONSULTS
HI BY BATES. HELEN HI HELEN HI
BUT YOU LET IT HI MARCH WITH A
HIGH TECH- RIGHT HI CORTESE FI
CORTESE I. DALI HI DOLLY HI DOT.
HI DON HI WHERE. BELINDA'S MAN
HI MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI
RUBIO HI RUBIO HI SKINNER NOT
VOTING. NUMBER NUMBER HI BY
CASKEY HI FORECAST P. FIVE WELL.
WELCOME I. THIRTEEN BUCKS OKAY
THANK YOU SECONDS- CONSENT
CALENDAR ADOPTED- NOW WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE FILE ORDER. ELLS ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT WILL START
FROM THE TOP. VALID NUMBER. TWO
A. B. ONE ONE SEVEN. OCEANS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY THE CHAIR VOTING HI THE
VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING. IT'S
HELEN HI ELLEN HI. THE ONLY. HI
DOLLY HI. WHERE LANDIS MAN MAN
I REVEAL. REVEAL I SCANNER HI
SKINNER HI NUMBER. NUMBER I.
FOURTEEN VOTES THANK YOU A. B.
ONE ONE SEVEN IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER. FIVE EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK.
G. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING I'D THE VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. BATES HELEN HI
HELEN HI WHERE. BELINDA'S MAN.
REVEALED BY RUBIO HI SKINNER
FIVE SKINNER HI NUMBER NUMBER
HI. THIRTEEN BOATS THIRTEEN
VOTES THAT GETS ENOUGH TO GET
OUT SO THANK YOU MR TICKETS ON
THE NEXT BILL IS OUT OF SIX
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REQUEST. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR
VOTING EYES VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. BATES ALAN HI ALAN HI
DOLLY THIS. MCGUIRE REQUIRE
HIGH BELINDA THIS MEN ARE MEN
HI NEWMAN. SKINNER SKINNER I-
THIRTEEN VOTES THANK YOU NEXT
PHIL IS FILE ITEM EIGHT AB.
ELEVEN NINETY SIX. ELEVEN
NINETY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
I THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
BASE ALAN HI ALAN I WHERE HI
WHERE HI LINDA IT'S- IN. MINHAI
NEWMAN. SKINNER FIVE SKINNER HI.
FOURTEEN VOTES OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT THE
NEXT ITEM IS VALID OR NINE AB
TEN THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SELES. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR
VOTING I THE VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. BATES. ALAN HI ALAN HI.
BUT WHERE I WHERE I WENT IS.
MAN YES HI RUBIO. I'M SO UPSET
WITH HIM. ALL RIGHT BYE.
SKINNER. FIVE FIFTEEN VOTES
OKAY THANK YOU THAT BILL GETS
OUT AND WE HAVE TWO MEMBERS WHO
ARE NOT COMING BACK SO WE'RE
GONNA TAKE IT BACK TO THE TOP-
WE HAVE A FEW MEMBERS HAVE
JOINED US MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT VIOLATED NUMBER TWO
PLEASE. AB ONE ONE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. SHARE VOTING I VICE
CHAIR NONVOTING BATES. REQUIRED
RIGHT. HI BELINDA'S. FIFTEEN
VOTES OKAY THAT BILL IS
FORMALLY L. UT OF THANK YOU
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SHOWBOATING I VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. BATES REQUIRE HIGH WIRE
HI BELINDA'S MEN. FOURTEEN
VOTES OKAY FOURTEEN VOTES THE
BILL GETS OUT. WELL IT IS SIX
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REBUS. ONE OF
THE PEOPLE IF. HOLD. NINE
EIGHTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SHAREHOLDING I'VE VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. BATES DOLLY.
MELINDA'S NEWMAN. THIRTEEN
VOTES THANK YOU THAT THOSE
FORMALLY OUT AGAIN FILE ITEM
EIGHT DB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
PLEASE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR BUILDING I'VE VICE CHAIR
NOT VOTING. BATES BELINDA'S
NEWMAN. FOURTEEN VOTES OKAY
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT AS
WELL AND A. B. TEN THIRTY FIVE
LAST ONE FOR SOLACE AND I WILL
GO BACK TO THE CONSENT
CALENDARS THANK YOU. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
I THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
BATES MELINDA'S. FIFTEEN VOTES
OKAY A. B. TEN THIRTY FIVE IS
FORMALLY OUT YET AGAIN SO ONCE
AGAIN WE'LL GO BACK TO THE
CONSENT CALENDARS- THE BILLS ON
CONSENT ONCE AGAIN AB. SEVEN
FORTY FOUR EIGHTY NINE NINETY
TWO AB THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
EIGHTY THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
949-980-3240. 475-152-6460
SEVEN- THIS COULD FIRST BUILT A
SET OF BILLS WILL BE LESS ACR
FIFTY ONE. WE DON'T SEE ANY
OBJECTION AT THIS TIME SO WE'LL
TAKE THE VOTE PLEASE FOR. I A.
C. R. I'M SORRY FOR THIS- FIRST
CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR THE FIRST
CONSENT CALENDAR. BATES THE
WIRE BY WIRE HI BELINDA'S MEN
MEN HI. FIFTEEN VOTES THANK YOU
FOR THAT FIRST CONSENT CALENDAR
IS APPROVED AND ADOPTED THE
SECOND WILL BE THE REMAINING
NAMING RESOLUTIONS ON THE
AGENDA CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE SECOND ONE PLEASE.
BASE HELLO. HI WHERE HI MELINDA
IT'S. YEAH. FOURTEEN VOTES OKAY
THANK YOU THAT FINALIZES ALL OF
OUR BILLS AND CONSENT. GOOD
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR MEN THAT
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION- WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.